mobile games landscape has been changing
faster than ever with millions of new
Android users coming online especially
in the emerging markets such as
Southeast Asia Latin America
it's become essential to understand the
market and ride the next growth rate my
name's Eric Oh I'm the vice president of
business development at bay marble the
marble was established in 2000 in South
Korea as a PC online game developer and
publisher around 2011 we tributed to
mobile game and had a series of metal
hit titles then it's evolution is a top
PC online game in Korea and its mobile
version was a blockbuster hit since day
one launched in December 2016
[Music]
customer care
completely localized in bahasa and we
also introduced an Indonesian character
in the gameplay to kamikaze gamers I
mean when a pants up another pricing and
that's why I
our biggest challenge was tackling the
low IP awareness one-month pre-launch we
used Google play's pre-registration
future amplifying this with marketing
and an on-site showcase we also launched
them probably in donation channel on
YouTube we're a very successful launch
in in the nation
we received 1.5 banana iterations and
the game hit number one on the gross
ranking chart and the first day of the
launch and the game still missed hot pan
today we already knew how important the
localization and having the right
marketing strategy was but the success
in Indonesia reinforced the importance
of the Imams motto is to create fun game
to the global gamers and we are doing
our best
[Applause]